also here at five the man who hit and
killed
five cyclists on u.s 95 last december
will spend a minimum of 16 years in
prison
the sentencing coming after two days of
very emotional testimony from the
victim's family
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
was there and joins us now in the studio
with more on what happened today sally
denise a judge sentenced barston to a
total of 16 to 40 years in prison
that includes two sentences to be served
consecutively each eight to 20 years
today's sentencing comes after two days
of emotional testimonies
from wives siblings children and friends
of the victims
many describing the big boy that was
left behind after losing their loved
ones
on december 10th some say they will
never be able to forgive
parson i pray
you receive the maximum sentence because
that is not enough
it will never be enough i'm standing
here
i'm standing here asking and
begging for a fair justice for my
husband
and his cycling mates
it's justice that they deserve i am very
forgiving person
but i cannot forgive you yet
and april barson entered a plea
agreement where his charges were reduced
and today the 45 year old pled guilty to
two counts
of dui resulting in death barson
admitted to having methamphetamine
in his system when he struck the cyclist
before the sentencing barson expressed
remorse to the families
and told them after he gets out of
prison he wants to go to rehab and share
his story
brian